they put cameras you could go online and
see the Titanic at any time you want
pretty cool and it would protect you sir
wait they're gonna turn the Titanic into
a webcam girl yeah do you want to see a
piece of my home this is a wanna see a
sticky wagon wheel yeah no this is a
pearl hairbrush it's a very serious I'm
sorry I didn't mean to turn the tide
all right so to catch up Sal on what
we're talking about is a girl flipped
out on her boyfriend and keyed his car
and he filmed it in JSON on worldstar
and we talked about it on the bonfire
this is the video it's like maybe a 30
second video lost my mind yeah that's
cool I got video proof of you doing this
you're crazy bro you're crazy
let me leave yeah me blocked in let me
leave you're kidnapping me let me leave
I just totally understand that point cuz
I've gotten there so many times we go
okay now we're but I'm being serious now
you gotta move cuz I got to leave you're
gonna get me in trouble do you mean
trouble at work
oh yeah I said that I said I've done
that thing with Christine where it's
like she's something like where if we're
arguing and she'll be like J like stop
we're putting here my arm I go I don't
want you to touch me
you're assaulting me technically right
now you're assaulting you and touching
me right now you know that right I don't
want to be touched by you right now
you're touching me you're assaulting me
habeas corpus
right now this is a mistrial it's a
double jeopardy okay give me twice for
the same crime you're my property you
assaulted me you're assaulting me
I've accused Christine of assault
seventy five times and you know what a
drunk Kristine accuses you of not being
able to produce anything does get
volatile you don't have a producer about
it you don't have a production one of my
favorite my favorite because it's such a
sweet funny thing to read production
bone in your body I wanna see if I can
ever cut like the video of it just for
looting at the audio it's a great thing
I here's the thing you gotta ask Christy
because hearing your drunk self is one
of the worst things in the world it's
like seeing yourself in one if if
Christine doesn't believe that one of
the funniest things ever in the world we
said out loud is do you think I'm so
supposable
well I go suppose both she goes yeah she
was supposed ball she goes it's the word
J look it up in the urban dictionary and
then I went I'll look it up wherever you
want me to look it up that's not a word
anywhere and she goes exactly basically
that's so funny
she did this Cecily strong girl you
never want to talk party yes make up
back in her bag and she dumped the purse
up three times in one conversation by
accident yeah there was where's my
favorite penny
so anyways to bring everyone up to point
that's who we're having Colin is the
girl here video her name black Lou
what's her name her name is autumn row
autumn row look at cute chick very
friendly super hot and black will you've
talked to her already few times have you
spoken on words yet like on the phone
yeah no no this will be the first time
you hear in her voice yes you've been
begging for me I went Jesus I feel like
she's young oh you know what I'll tell
you why father a schoolgirl uniform
she's definitely a possible foot soldier
no but every photo is just a selfie of
her and everyone has almost filters with
the big fake eyes and yeah yeah like
it's a younger thing yeah that's a jab
or Japanese culture yeah yeah Japanese
anime oh yeah her mom's Irish your dad's
anime yeah dad was actually he's half
Dragonball Z a little bit exotic is
probably the japanimation y'all just mad
I'm cute lol bitches hate me cuz they
ain't me forget Christine you have that
tattooed on your forearm yeah in Latin
[Laughter]
Kyra Lee has our identity been revealed
from that video and she's be gotten
viral I think she's leaning in she's
calling her to this show so she has to
be leaning in at some point black Lou
you said she's leaning into it yeah she
told me I don't know how true it is but
she has been in LA all week last week
she told me that she was going to LA to
shoot dr. Phil so I wanted to get babies
we convinced her that dr. Phil's also on
the show
again autumn how are you by the way
there's rumors I saw someone on Twitter
so that Maggie got put down I'm serious
look it up I saw that too
cuz if Maggie's dead there has to be a
Chicago Dick's funeral a lot of filters
what it is right now is it is probably
just raining dick offers on her oh my
god the first question has to be how
many of dick pics that you get well
she's just like a normal civilian in the
world right how many followers as yet
10.8 thousand that's a lot for this week
a girl a place yeah a girl in a place a
girl in a place she's in a tough place
I'm gonna write a musical with her
called the summer of autumn
man that makes you fall in love and then
you got a trap um in an apartment
complex parking lot keying up his Nissan
a clue were you at with her in
conversation what's going on she's
calling you to defend her case of
watches it wants to tell her side of the
story
absolutely I don't want to get in too
deep I wanted to let you guys do you
feel that she'll be forthcoming look I
want to know is is that our first keyed
car exactly what's your technique is it
a down the thing RZA's up and down it's
gonna I give the guy props for not being
like I have to stop you from keying my
car yeah it's AG Nissan to watch the
video but behind the scenes are trying
to figure out the boyfriend's race yes
behind these medals I really think it's
a blank grid let's do it let's open up
the betting pool right now I say but
most of us are locked down the same
thing a Hispanic yeah I think this guy's
Hispanic Latino what do you think do you
think he's mixed Blake Griffin
basketball pristine what do you got you
think Hispanic DJ low CC Jacob Black man
Sal from what I believe that one play I
think Dominican Dominicans so you're
gonna go Hispanic we're gonna go Latino
super s but we're Sheen she lives in LA
she didn't say where she lives she just
said she was flying but this is good
there's a good blind bet because if we
knew the region yeah it would it would
affect every can I change mine yeah
because we didn't find out things yeah
I'm gonna go Mexicano Meimei McConnell
okay I'm gonna go if we're going
specific Hispanic my answer would be
different than Dominican I would go
Porto Rican I was gonna go Colombian or
Oh me I'm or maybe a mad race night
cheeky I would say I'm actually I don't
know black Lou makes a good point he
might change in MA you know what can we
play it one more time just one more time
because I might change I think I like
the black and white mix okay the scary
to me is the way cool you don't need to
give a that's cool I got video
proof of you doing this you're crazy
right yeah I'm changing it I think he's
black and white ladies mix please a mix
mix mix black a I'm gonna go crazy
left-field okay I'm gonna go like an
Asian with urban flair oh I love it yeah
did not think that Oh girls getting by
an Asian dude oh it is a Nissan
[Music]
yeah on the phonelines very excited to
have her on we prepped you a little bit
before the break on the story so
intrigued now to hear the story
questions but also we know a lot of
perspectives that we haven't heard well
and I'm saying and it's something that
upon watching it it's black or white
everyone's either behind her yeah or
going like uh crazy broad so I would
love to have her here too on the line
here to explain the story and we'll get
to know her a little bit everyone autumn
ro ought to be there yeah how are you
thank you for being on hold there for us
I know sorry Michael McDonald was
singing everyone we caught up you know I
tried to turn on the mics they wouldn't
turn on they wanted us to hear Michael
McDonald your video autumn a viral
sensation on WorldStarHipHop I still
have a dream of having something of mine
I can't in the world get a video on
WorldStarHipHop but you made the cut
which was awesome I don't know if you're
loving the attention not liking it fill
us in well at first I really hated it
but honestly I don't really care anymore
people's opinions of me just they don't
really bother me anymore okay would it
happen but I've also had a lot of like
positive reactions forming a lot of
women reaching out to me that you know
have been through similar things that
I've been through so that brings this
kind of to one of the questions we were
wondering because we are producer Lou
Black Lou LJ as Sean Furey calls him
said that he knows a lot of these
stories and the dudes always do
something crazy to merit this and all
you got was the reaction shot of you
King up his and let me guess this
properly
Nissan Maxima yes it was actually a
rental car but did he rent from
enterprise yeah oh man nailed that first
off autumn thank you for confirming what
I already knew which is that Enterprise
has the best deal on Nissan's day-to-day
also autumn a second question now we
have a bet going on the show
because we don't see his face we just
heard it was this your ex-boyfriend I
don't know what to call him
what do we call him your ex yes yeah he
was my ex-boyfriend we dated for about
two years
all right so he's her boyfriend of two
years and we had a guess there are seven
of us and we all guessed what ethnicity
he was he used bra
he used we were trying to guess from the
way he talked what he what was your
ex-boyfriend he was white and black our
one and only black staff member called
it ah which means we are ignorant pink
racist we had a couple Dominicans we we
had an Asian urban Asian guest from
South yeah my my guess was I thought I
heard him going when he's saying you're
kidnapping me you're kidnapping me bro
she sounded very shallow to me yeah now
you thought it was some hat I'm an idiot
now if you would you mind autumn at all
telling the story of what led up to this
moment because it really is the only
context of it is girl losing her
but there's got to be a reason he did
that was his point it was his point to
make me look like I was crazy that's
what he wanted to gain from this video
and looks like he gains that yeah so
what happened what led what led to this
moment so actually before the video was
taken you only see his side really so
before the video was taken we're at my
apartment where he assaulted me but his
hands on me like he does all the time we
had a lot of domestic problems through
our relationship of two years so we're
at my part with it and he assaulted me
and stole my cell phone and I had
already paid to fix my phone about four
times that month and I had to buy a new
phone because he broke the last one so
God so I was pretty angry that he took
my phone so I got my car wasn't there on
time because he had dropped me off at my
house so I got an uber to my car and I
was just you know chilling in my car
rolling up but to chill you know take my
mind off and what just happened and he
pulls up behind my car at chick-fil-a
blocks my car
he starts like beaming they're recording
me so you were in the parking lot and
again you'e we have to say we have to
say illegally say it was it was you know
he allegedly assaulted you because we
can't be you know legally put on the
line for this but you're saying he he
allegedly assaulted you and then you and
then this is later in the day you were
just in the parking lot and then this is
when he pulled up no this is exactly
this is like okay so right when that
happened I got an uber to my car so this
is all within like an hour and a half
time span okay so you guys are fighting
you you leave you go to get your taking
uber to your car yes so he but his
Maxima is in the parking lot and your
car is blocking him in so how did yeah
so I so how did you get to there if you
were parked and then he blocked you in
mmm-hmm so because we are at chick-fil-a
has my car blocked I Drive over the curb
to get out and then boy he starts
driving off and I'm like you know what I
want my phone back and this dude's made
me pay so much money between country
holes in my wall allegedly punching
holes in my walls oh no you can claim it
you can claim the actual assault on the
wall we're just worried about we don't
think the wall will sue serious attack
walls are free drywall doesn't have
access to legal so he would punch holes
in walls also I just want to say as a
video game player that can be a cause of
it so he cost you so much money that you
go to stop him from leaving yeah well
yeah I go to and I'm like you know I'm
gonna make him you know pay for money he
starts recording like Joyce doesn't like
you in a recording I'm gonna give you a
show and that's kind of why I was
smiling in the video I was like I'm
tired of you making me pay for all this
stuff it's your turn to pay for
something I'm gonna see your car so I
can his car so it wasn't even cheap I
think we all just assumed it was going
to be it has nothing to do with him
dumping me or cheating on he drove to my
house right after that it tried his best
to get me back he was like begging me
saying he was so sorry he definitely did
not cheat on me definitely did not break
up with me also did he have a rental
fender-bender oh yeah he had like gotten
into a friend over there like a week or
two before
so keying the rental car actually isn't
even that big a deal because that's
going back insurance did he buy the
insurance well I guess the question I'm
asking is he more half white or half
black now what has he been your dealings
with him since we actually this video
was taken in May I broke up with him
about oh you stay together after this
you stay together after this night yeah
we did get back together I bet I don't
know if you did but if you guys hooked
up that night I bet it was great intense
just like kissy-face punches so you guys
I'm sorry I wasn't paying attention
you guys you guys got back together I
was laughing about your joke oh so I'm
sorry the half white or half black big
it killed me you guys aren't back
together or have not been back together
no we broke up about like I said about
two weeks ago and that's when the video
went viral is because I broke up with
him so he sent it around to everybody -
oh so you guys had made up after
this and then he put it viral
what-have-you and you haven't spoke to
him since the video went viral right I'm
actually in Los Angeles and we're about
to go on the dr. Phil show well what if
I told you dr. Phil was here right now
oh you go on dr. Phil with the guy
you're going on right now have you
filmed it yet and we are filming
tomorrow and whoever's impersonation of
dr. Phil that was trash it was not a
good impersonation for you I'll fight
you oaky your car I'll fight you in a
park
I don't know I don't know why she's such
a big dr. Phil fan she can't on the
guy a little bit you know are you
going on with the ex-boyfriend yes I'm
telling my side of the story you know
have proof to back everything that I've
been through up so you're gonna be there
with him like a Grogg you know it's not
like you guys are going on together
you're going there like adversaries we
have to go on at different times because
I have a restraining order against him
no
so it's dr. Phil so he went to jail wait
for this for not for this video but for
other assaults which if he has been
convicted or legal so we can tell you
I'll tell you after this dr. Phil
appearance if you have any any lyrics
inside of you that you can drop a few
rap bars yeah we'll get looked at for at
least a record dr. Phil is a kingmaker
really I know do you have do you know
I'm gonna watch dr. Phil to nail
on this impression because apparently
it's trash you're kidnapping me
yeah it doesn't even matter I'm
surprised part that we made us laugh the
hardest is when your ex-boyfriend goes
you're kidnapping me yeah I'm saying I'm
surprised you got back with a guy and
gained a chance for sexual attraction to
a guy who yelled you're kidnapping me to
you that seems like such a weird thing
to get Pat you know hey autumn Berkeley
our producer has a question is the is
the like athlete of some sort because he
seems very tall from the video play ball
at all black blue is going for the
trifecta Christine we have Christine on
the show here
same scenario she describes do you
Yukie up a car physical did you have a
thing everywhere the guy were you paid
for everything and got taken advantage
of like that no just me how did you two
meet
really he's reached out black Lu how
many kids does he have oh I got one more
question Columbo you said that the car
was borrowed from I know if you're
renting a car you got to get insurance
on it is that a trash Columbo : you
think there's a chance do you think
there's a chance that his kids mom have
you and the kids mom had beef before
over the two years right nope I'm saying
sometimes they come at you might have
come at you yeah there's so there's been
no drama with the baby mama no well
that's good at least
yeah that's I'm so excited to watch the
episode of dr. Phil now I want to see
him so bad do you feel like you're in
you you still have feelings for me you
feel like you're you've had it last
straw you're completely over him there's
no chance of you ever even reconsidering
him no no chance
it's a weird left hand that's a real try
to flip it around
well black Lou I'll tell you on our
squad here black Lou is team autumn all
the way 100% so if you needed somebody
to call and dr. Phil and give a a
shining testimony it's gonna be black
Lou he's had your back from since we
watched the video
he didn't doubt you from the from the
second we watch the video black Lou said
that dude did some fucked-up yeah
that's exactly what he said she's won
you over to g1 Jacob over autumn loves
hard she does love hard
bonham could I interest you in a radio
producer named Jacob baton I mean you're
single now this guy will not do he's got
his own cashola Jacob how do you feel
about a maritime law how about what
maritime law sea law just the ocean laws
yeah yeah shipwreck if you lie your
fault you don't know this it's maritime
laws it's a different set of laws and
standards from other sovereign nations
or any other international bodies
basically let's get to the nuts and
bolts of this thing how do you feel
about shipwrecks are you a Titanic fan I
mean you know what Jacob you could show
hearts I'd say how old are you autumn if
you might be asking I'm 20 now I
wouldn't either
I know anything about books no the
things that float in the ocean that is
crazy
yeah that's gonna freak you out a lot
well autumn good luck on dr. Phil yeah
have a great show I hope your point gets
out there and you make this guy look
like an asshole that he is right black
blue yes indeed
thank you so much for calling us yeah
all right we'll be right back after this
it's the bonfire she's got real 20
year-old girl at the end where she
didn't start understanding the
references you know like when you're
confused to get angry
sure thrashing I almost got Keith dude
no she try to come for you I mean that
girl on our Instagram is hot yeah it's
pretty hot chick young but definitely
hot 20 you guys were right the Columbo
impression probably flew overhead like
enough air space for it to be
cleared for foot your your dr. Phil
impression it's garbage oh my god you're
dr. Phil you suck Sal thank you so much
for hanging out with this face thank you
guys have fun always always blessed you
got to meet your future lunatic
ex-girlfriend autumn row which I guess
you can catch coming up soon on dr. Phil
but don't worry I'll dock home Phil not
that hunk of impression we get in
this ass studio I wish our the
best I do I do think I need to be
exposed oh yeah but also like my dr.
Phil oppressions pretty good it is good
you